hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt eine der meist gestellten
fragen in meinen kommentaren ist immer
die überm einer küchenmaschine also ich
werde oft gefragt sei nie was vergüten
maschinen hast du wieso hast du drei
küchenmaschine was sind die vor und die
nachteile und deswegen habe ich jetzt
auch schon lange zeit dieses video
geplanten und möchte endlich ein video
über meine küchenmaschine machen
es gibt ja schon zahlreiche
küchenmaschine tests im internet oder
auch im fernsehen stiftung warentest
oder ökotest oder alle möglichen tests
gibt und da muss man sich aber immer
fragen wer sponsert diesen test also
bezahlt diesen test und dann ist es mal
so dass maschine bei diesem test sehr
gut abschneidet und beim nächsten test
irgendwie bei befriedigend oder
ausreichend ist und es gibt aber auch
ganz viele internet foren wo schon über
küchenmaschinen diskutiert wird und wo
es sich einfach nutzer gegenseitig
helfen und hilfestellungen geben
aber auch da ist es so dass man hier
eigentlich alles normaler mensch eine
küchenmaschine hat und dann von der
entweder komplett begeistert ist oder
eben gar nicht begeistert ist und ich
mache dieses video weil ich ja drei
küchenmaschinen habe die ich auf jeden
tag benutzt und ich habe die auch schon
sehr lange mein thermomix zb der schock
über zwei jahre als die kitchenaid ist
schon über eineinhalb jahre alt und
jetzt habe ich ja auch nicht die candies
etwas sechs monate alt und ich habe
jetzt die küchenmaschinen echt langer
zeit benutzt und kann deswegen sagen was
meiner meinung nach die vor und die
nachteile sind und wie einfach meine
persönliche meinung zu allen drei
maschinen ist und deswegen habe ich
jetzt dieses video hier und möchte ich
das jetzt einfach mal vorstellen
zuerst muss ich jetzt mal fragen brauche
ich überhaupt eine küchenmaschine also
bevor ich mir zu hause eine
küchenmaschine kaufen würde weil es mir
wichtiger für mich und meine gesundheit
dass ich eine gute matratze in meinem
bett damit ich keine rückenschmerzen
bekommen und dass ich zum beispiel ein
gutes schuhwerk
denn wir müssen jeden tag draußen laufen
das schuhwerk ist viel wichtiger als der
küchenmaschine die zu hause steht in der
werbung wird oft gesagt diese
küchenmaschine kocht gesund die
küchenmaschine kann ich
kochen ihr seid dass die gesund kocht
die zutaten sind wichtig und eure
zubereitungs weise und wenn das alles
stimmt und ihr euch dann dazu
entschlossen habt eine küchenmaschine zu
kaufen dann müsst ihr erst mal abwägen
wie ihr kocht und welche küchenmaschine
dazu passt denn es kann nicht sein dass
die küchenmaschine bestimmt wie ihr zu
kochen habt die küchenmaschine muss zu
euren kochstil oder teuren bugs team
passen und dementsprechend müssen dass
er daneben aussuchen
jetzt ist es aber erst mal wichtig zu
wissen was es für verschiedene
küchenmaschinen gibt es gibt zum
beispiel einmal die version dass man von
oben hier dieses werk hat bei der
kitchen aid ist das planetarische
rührwerk als ich einmal dieser
schneebesen dreht und dann noch hier
dieses gerät dreht es gibt aber auch bei
etwas günstigeren maschinen wie zum
beispiel aus dem discounter das ist
jetzt das gerät von meiner mama das hat
sie auch nicht mehr lange und dann gibt
es andere geräte wie zum beispiel der
technik dies sahen auch andere firmen
bildern von unten dieses system haben
und die sind eben perfekt um zb zum
mixen oder zu pürieren also zum beispiel
wenn man mal nicht zu bekommen
ich konnte mir nicht wirklich perfekt
und dann gibt es aber auch kombigeräte
wie zum beispiel die kenwood die hat
dann die falsche seite jetzt hier hatte
die hat hier dieses planetarische rühren
hier oben und hat er hier oben noch den
aufsatz damit hier oben auch so rühren
kann und von unten her diesen mixa hat
der übrigen ziemlich richtig
abgetrocknet wurde aber das machen und
dessen jetzt wird die unterschiede als
einmal die von oben mit dem
planetarischen rohrsystem einmal die mit
dem mixer von unten und einmal diese
kombi geräte und wenn ihr euch dann dazu
entschlossen haben eine küchenmaschine
zu kaufen gibt es einfach ein paar tipps
und zwar würde ich immer sagen geht zu
einem fachhändler
denn nur bei einem fachhändler könnt ihr
euch die richtige beratung holen
also ich bin immer gegen einen internet
kauf wobei ich ja auch einen online-shop
habe aber wir sind eben in online
fachhändler bei uns gibt es die
küchenmaschinen dann vom fachhändler vor
ort dann kann man anrufen kann aber auch
hingehen wenn man probleme zum beispiel
mal hätte oder einfach auch fragen zur
maschine hat und er berät
es gibt aber auch bei den fachhändlern
einige unterschiede
ich hatte ja dass mein mann immer so
wenn ich zum beispiel einen sportfan
suche und zu einem fachmarkt gehen dann
gibt es einfach vor zwei arten von
verkäufern es gibt den einen damit zum
beispiel gleich mit meiner größe fragt
und es gibt den anderen denn ich noch
dass sportart fragt und genau diese
zweite version brauchen wir einfach
anders und euch nicht frage für welches
budget ihr dass die küchenmaschine
brauchen natürlich es ist auch wichtig
aber wichtiger ist es für welche
verwendung also was was wollt ihr denn
damit herstellen wollte damit mehr
kochen backen wollt ihr mixer pürieren
oder reiben und das ist das was wichtig
ist damit die küchenmaschine auch zu
euch passt
es gibt nämlich nicht die eine perfekte
maschine für alle menschen auch das kann
eine perfekte maschine genau für euch
geben und für eure werte mit der nyse
und ich hatte ja oft im shop gefragt
sally du hast der die kitchenaid in shop
und du hast dir kennwort im shop aber du
hast auch im thermomix und welche
küchenmaschine würdest du mir empfehlen
und ich frage dann eben immer für was
brauchst du sie hast du eine kleine
familie eine große familie
oder ist es zum beispiel so wenn einer
jetzt sagt ich möchte damit einfach nur
den weg frei für meine tochter machen
oder ein paar sachen kochen oder meine
körner zu feinem mehl mahlen dann
empfehle ich den thermomix mir jetzt
aber eine sagt ich mag auch ganz viel
und bürgersteige dann empfehle ich die
kitchenaid und wenn er bei einer fragt
ich hätte gerne eine maschine die teig
rühren kann aber auch mal etwas mixen
kann und zum beispiel meine karotten
installieren streifen schneiden
dann empfehle ich die kenwood aber es
kommt einfach auch darauf an wie groß
ihre familie ist die kitchenaid es sind
zum beispiel hat zwar einen recht hohen
mixa hält aber damit behält davon der
fanbus ist natürlich noch größer und da
fast noch mehr rein und auch in ganz
wichtigen tipp natürlich gibt es bei mir
die kitchenaid und die canon wurde im
shop den thermomix gibt's bei mir
natürlich nicht den kammern online nicht
kaufen sondern muss direkt über vorwerk
über eine beraterin dieser maschine
kaufen was ich auch sehr gut finde weil
nur die beraterinnen euch vor ort direkt
erklären können wie die maschine
funktioniert und auch was es drauf
ankommt mieter war immer ganz wichtig
dass man sich küchenmaschinen nicht
finanziert ich habe zwar bei mir im shop
die finanzierungsmöglichkeit auch drin
weil einfach viele anfragen da waren
aber ich
persönlich der meinung dass man sich
küchenmaschinen nicht finanzieren sollte
ich hab da einfach immer angst dass
menschen dadurch in die schuldenfalle
geraten können wenn sie sich schon die
einfachsten sachen finanzieren
ich finde man kann sich im haus fehlern
zählen man kann sich eine wohnung finden
sehen um ein auto finanzieren
aber ich bin küchenmaschinen sollte man
sich nicht finanzieren sondern sie erst
dann kaufen wenn man das geld dazu hat
und wenn man da mal ein jahr darauf
sparen muss ist es auch nicht schlimm
lieber kaufmann es dann wenn das geld
hat und dann ist er gleich abbezahlt und
wenn ihr euch dann dazu entschlossen hat
eine maschine zu kaufen solltet ihr auf
jeden fall auf die qualität achten
ihr nehmt euch dann ja auch euer geld
und gibt es aus und wollte dann auch
lange zeit was davon haben
ich kenne leute die haben schon seit
über 30 jahren den thermomix ich kenne
leute die haben seit 20 jahren weg ist
oder noch länger
und ich kenne leute die haben schon
jahrelang eine can boot und es sind
einfach dinge die gehen nicht kaputt und
wenn sie kaputt gehen gibt es natürlich
ersatzteile und es gibt eine lange
garantie und ich sag ich es einfach mal
ein paar kleinigkeiten wo ihr schon an
der qualität den unterschied erkennen
könnt das erste was natürlich ins auge
sticht ist das gehäuse bei kitchenette
und canvas sind es zum beispiel beides
aluguss gehäuse die maschinen sind sehr
schwer und es ist auch sehr wichtig dass
ich schwer sind denn die stehen auf der
arbeitsfläche und müssen darauf stehen
auch wenn es einmal zum beispiel in den
schweren nudelteig kneten da kann's
nämlich bei anderen maschinen was ihr
bei der die leicht ist dass das gehäuse
wackelt und die maschine sich doch von
der arbeitsplatte weg bewegt und
erzählte kunststoffgehäuse und da kann
es einfach passieren dass es in
kürzester zeit verschleiß und ihr eben
nicht lange zeit was von unten ganz
enormen unterschied kann man hier
erkennen und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
einmal den hörer von dieser marken
küchenmaschine hier ohne namen und zwar
sind es hier ganz normale zu
hier in einer kunststoffgehäuse und die
werden in kürzester zeit hier alle
ausbrechen
so war es auch mit meiner alten
küchenmaschine und hier sieht man das
auch alles hier aus kunststoff und aus
einfachen rat das wird euch kaputt gehen
sobald irgendwas angerührt und hier der
unterschied mit zu erkennen wo zum
beispiel das ist alles aus edelstahl ist
auch sehr massiv und sehr schwer ist
natürlich auch ein preislicher
unterschied für die can gekostet
wahrscheinlich das achtfache von dieser
maschine aber ihr habt einfach länger
was davon
ich war ja an der hochschule und da
gab's bei uns in der küche an jeder
küchenzeile eine böschung der sich ja
auch so möglichen maschine so in der
mittleren preisklasse ich glaube die
kosten um die 160 euro was ja eigentlich
viel geld ist aber für eine große
küchenmaschine relativ günstig ist und
die war okay aber sie hat zb keine
starren teig kneten können da laufen
solche maschinen einfach heißt und da
würd ich sagen kauf ich mir lieber keine
küchenmaschine sondern kaufte mir ein
gutes handrührgerät wirklich ein
qualitativ hochwertiges und knete meine
schweren teile weiterhin per habt und
nehmen dann dieses qualitativ
handrührgerät und zb meine urteil gewiss
beteilige oder eben meine sahne zu
schlagen und so würde ich das jetzt
persönlich zum beispiel machen und wo
wir uns gerade schon bei der qualität
werden ich habe neulich hat es gesehen
da hat zum beispiel das habe ich es ganz
schlecht abgeschnitten weil damit der
kitchenaid verglichen wurde und zwar
wurde getestet welche maschine kann
besser sein erschlagen
und mal ganz ehrlich da ist ja logisch
dass melkmaschine die unten
außer natürlich die sache nicht beruf
schlagen kann wie eine küchenmaschine
die dafür gebaute kitchenaid von oben
schlägt viel luft rein und sei damit die
sahne voluminösen und es ist so als
würde ich jetzt einen sportwagen mit
einem kombi waren vergleichen
der sportwagen ist schnell fahren und
der kombi so viele lachten fragen also
das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche
sachen und ich bin es da einfach nicht
ganz seriös wenn man einer
küchenmaschine einer guten
küchenmaschine eine schlechte note gibt
nur weil sie eben bei diesem test jetzt
die anforderungen oder diesen
anforderungen nicht gerecht wurde aber
dafür wird sie ja gar nicht gemacht
hatte die maschine mit sport und dieser
hier wird eben gut
ich möchte jetzt hier heute nicht mehr
auf details eingehen ich möchte nämlich
jetzt jede woche eine biete zu einer
maschine machen
nächste woche werde ich mit meiner
kenwood starten und da waren wir hier
schon so viele anfragen
ich hab euch alle ganz lange vertrösten
müssen und die woche später wenn ich
dann noch mal ein video über die
kitchenaid machen wo ich einfach die
ganzen funktionen mit dem ganzen zubehör
zeige bei der tricks kann ich euch
leider nicht nicht beraten denn da
solltet ihr direkt über vorbeigehen und
da gibt's frauen und männer die euch das
zu hause dann zeigen können diese
maschine mit allen einzelheiten und ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video jetzt
geholfen hat so einen kleinen überblick
zu bekommen und ein paar hilfen wie ihr
euch für eine maschine entscheiden könnt
ich hab natürlich nicht die drei zu
hause
ich kenne auch keine anderen
küchenmaschinen aber dessen so die drei
marken die einfach in deutschland und
vielleicht sogar weltweit am meisten
verkauft werden und am meisten im
privaten haushalt einsatz finden
ich hoffe dass ich das video gewalt hat
in meine kommentare könnt ihr mal rein
schreiben ob er vielleicht auch schon
eine küchenmaschine habt oder ob ihr
euch demnächst eine zulegen werde
und ich freue mich schon aufs nächste
video und als ich auch nächste woche mit
meinem flug endet video
bis bald bis dann fertig die polar mist
nicht wirklich die colaflasche stehen
lassen
ich höre das jetzt doch hier alles extra
dekoriert sogar einen aufsteller nämlich
einfach der cola wenige hindurch nächste
kneipe oder auf und schaue nicht gesund
gern noch traurig ich habe auch wenn man
braucht wieder alles schmutzig ist